get ready to brood because here's every
movie in the DCE you so far first up Man
of Steel we open on Krypton which is the
midst of a military coup led by General
Zod planet is also literally doomed
crumbling from the inside now to save
their species brilliant scientist jor-el
steals the Codex a database containing
the genetic history of every Kryptonian
and implanted in their infant son kal-el
all Krypton's heirs living and they send
man earth to the one day and the time
was right you could be the bridge
between two peoples except the kal-el
lands on the Kansas farm of Jonathan
Kent who basically tells him not to save
anybody ever even himself so Kelly's
just kind of hanging out on earth being
Clark Kent
occasionally saving people on the DL but
meanwhile the Kryptonians captured
General Zod and the other mutineers and
blast them into the Phantom Zone in what
looks like big stone Wang's
but of course they find their way out
and come to earth looking for kal-el
also Zod's ship has a machine called the
world engine that can transform the
Earth's surface into a new version of
Krypton he plans to kill kal-el take the
Codex and repopulate the earth with
Kryptonians so that Krypton can live
again on earth
Clark battles the Kryptonians at his
hometown of Smallville earning the trust
of the US military this man is not our
enemy and gets a familiar nickname
Superman alien sir that's what they call
me
he joins up with the army to stop Dodds
world engine even though
michael shannon is so intense
anyway Superman destroys the ship along
with half of Metropolis and then fight
Zod and destroys the other half
finally Superman kills Zahn settles into
an uneasy peace government that's a 12
million dollar piece of hardware I'm
here to help and Clark finds himself
falling for plucky reporter Lois Lane
who gets him a job at the newspaper
where she works welcome to the planet
right cuz it's the Daily Planet
you see next up Batman V Superman we
start with a quick reminder when Batman
was a kid he watched his parents die and
this is important his mom's name is
Martha another reminder Bruce Wayne and
watched Superman fight sod and wreck
metropolis and he and the rest of the
world blamed Superman for that
destruction let the record show that
this committee holds him responsible
then it starts to get a little
convoluted so Lois Lane investigates the
slaughter of African rebels after
Superman rescues her and traces a fancy
bullet back to none other than Jolly
Rancher enthusiast and amateur
basketball player Lex Luthor
Batman investigates a boat that's
smuggling kryptonite and traces that
back to Lex Luthor as well Clark Kent
investigates Batman who's doing his best
to be the darkest Batman yet Bruce Wayne
keeps remembering his dead parents to
remind us once again that his mom's name
say it with me is Martha Lex Luthor
throws a fancy party and hey look who's
there Batman is Superman
cool they're gonna fight right no
there's just some lame foreshadowing Wow
that is a good grip you should not pick
a fight with this person huh
later Batman dozers awful investigating
Luthor and has a trippy dream of a
dystopian future run by Superman and
gets a warning from future flesh so he
decides to steal Lex Luthor's kryptonite
so he can protect the world from
Superman he is not our enemy
I mean good guys are left how many
stayed that way
Superman confronts Batman but they still
don't fight Superman is summoned to
Washington to testify before Congress
about why he thinks he can just go
around wrecking cities but then bland
for death and destruction
Superman feels so bad about not being
able to stop the bomb that he goes and
mopes in the wilderness Lex Luthor makes
a deal with the center for access to
Zod's crashed Kryptonian ship so he can
throw Zod in the Genesis chamber and mix
in some of his own blood and for some
reason he's crying
Batman discovers Lex's data contains
info on metahumans including that pretty
lady from the party and check it out
those guys are gonna be the Justice
League Lois figures out that Lex is
behind the Capitol bombing and
everything he's been doing is to try and
make Superman look like a d-bag he's
also been manipulating Batman to hate
Superman and yes I promise this is all
eventually leading up to something Lex
Luthor kidnapped Superman's mom who is
also named Martha and Lois Lane but then
immediately throws her office building
so Superman will catch her even though
the last time we saw him he was moping
on top of a mountain anyway he tells
Superman he has to kill Batman or he'll
kill his mom Son of Krypton versus bat
of Gotham
finally Superman in Batman fight Batman
quickly gets the upper hand thanks to
some kryptonite gas and a big metal
Batman Batman gets to find out that
Superman does bleed but before you can
kill them Superman's like yep a major
plot point in the movies based around
the completely random coincidence of
Superman and Batman's moms having the
same name so now Batman and Superman are
pretty much best friends and probably
the best scene in the movie Batman takes
out Luthor's goons and saves Martha
Superman heads to the Kryptonian ship
which is all Lightning II because the
Genesis chamber is done cooking up
doomsday because what would one of these
movies be if it didn't end with a huge
fight with a bad guy with godlike
abilities that destroys half the city
Superman is joined by Batman and Wonder
Woman she with you
I thought yours was here but doomsday is
too powerful trying to kill him only
makes him stronger until Superman
summons all his strength and uses the
kryptonite sphere to finally take him
down but not before doomsday mortally
wounds the weakened Superman himself and
so we wrap things up the world mourns
the death of Superman even though they
all hated unlike the day before much
thought there's captured in this deleted
scene where he seems to be hanging with
a hologram of Steppenwolf Bruce Wayne
sidles up to Diana Prince and is all
like me and want us done Justice League
Batman visits Luther in prison who
maniacally rants about ringing bells may
be a reference to Darkseid and that's it
can we please move on to Wonder Woman
now oh not yet Suicide Squad okay I'll
try to make this quick Amanda Waller has
the genius idea to assemble a task force
of the world's most menacing criminals
to take on missions that are impossibly
dangerous I want to build a team of some
very bad people who I think can do some
good and look how cool these characters
are yeah Deadshot he's a mercenary with
impeccable aim Harley Quinn she's crazy
Killer Croc a human crocodile thing El
Diablo who can do fire stuff Captain
Boomerang does a whole lot of nothing
and has an unexplained unicorn fetish
and of course their team leader who
isn't a criminal at all
Colonel Rick Flagg who's assisted by his
friend co-worker of acquaintance katana
and her soul stealing sword
this is katana she's got my back yeah
yeah yeah we get it
so the squad is activated to stop Rick's
girlfriend jus who's been possessed by
the evil spirit of The Enchantress a
powerful magical witch slash hula dancer
who wants to take over the world
she's got an army of pretty easy to kill
minions and also summons her brother
Incubus another powerful magical being
portrayed and stunning CGI not enough
plot for you don't worry while all of
this is happening the Joker is planning
on how to get Harley Quinn back and
embarks on his own journey to find her
okay this is a lot of characters oh we
forgot about Slipknot whose only Raw on
the team is to die
literally he doesn't even get a graphic
here comes Slipknot the man can climb
anything back to the mission the squad
finds out that their goal wasn't to save
the world but merely to extract amanda
waller from the building she was trapped
in but after they rescue her they decide
to do the right thing and stop and
chanters anyways because otherwise the
movie would be over I'm gonna get you to
you wanna end this Diablo Hulk's out
becomes a self-sacrificing fire monster
to stop Incubus and Harley's able to
exercise and tantras from June's body
and they all live happily ever after
getting they all go back to jail the end
time for the crown jewel of the DC EU
Wonder Woman
young Diana grew up on the difficult to
pronounce island of the mosquito ruled
by benevolent warriors the Amazons and
their Queen Diana's mom Hippolyta she
teaches Diana that Zeus created mankind
but his son Aerys grew jealous so he
turned men into a-holes that just want
to kill each other
the Amazons believe that one day Ares
will return to plunge humanity into
endless war but they have a weapon the
god killer that can defeat him that
mascara is hidden away from the world
behind a protective barrier of magic
father except one day American spies
Steve Trevor crashes his plane into the
ocean near the island tells Diana about
World War 1 the war to end all wars and
she becomes convinced this is the
prophesied return to Mary's only Ares
could do such a thing so she leaves
Steve to go kill her they take an
extremely fast boat ride to London where
Diana has a bit of trouble adjusting to
the modern world and arrive on the front
lines where Diana finally gets to show
Steve her superhero skills
yes this is awesome
they pose for that one photograph hey
there it is and also oh yeah they fall
in love
Steve's on a mission to stop the evil
general ludendorf and his associate a
chemist named dr. Poisson who's
designing a deadly new gas Dyna believes
that Ludendorff is Ares Ludendorff is
airings see but after she kills him and
the war keeps going anyway she figures
out that Ares is actually that guy from
Harry Potter you Diana also realizes her
sword isn't the god killer it's actually
just some dumb regular sword but as the
daughter of Zeus and Volta Diana herself
is the god killer I'm dear child and
he's not the god Canha you are after
Diana see Steve sacrificed his own life
to save everyone from dr. poisons gas
bombs she realizes Humanity is worth
fighting for after all and saves the day
spoiler alert
World War one ends and we meet up with
her in the present day ready to spring
into action and fight the doubter space
mercenary bug guys or whatever happens
in the Justice League
[Music]
you